one of the things that an llm is good at
is actually deep biasing
um and so you can feed it a news article
and you can tell it strip out the bias
yeah that's nice right and it actually
does it like it actually knows how to do
that because it knows how to do among
other things it actually knows how to do
sentiment analysis and so it knows how
to pull out the emotionality yeah
um and so uh that's one of the things
you can do it's very suggestive of the
of the the the the sense here that
there's real potential in this issue
um you know I would say look the second
thing is there's this there's this issue
of hallucination right um and there's a
long conversation that we could have
about that Hallucination is uh coming up
with things that are totally not true
but sound true yeah so it's basically
well so it's sort of Hallucination is
what we call it when we don't like it
creativity is what we call it when we do
like it right
um and you know brilliant right and and
so when the engineers talk about it
they're like this is terrible it's
hallucinating right if you have an
artistic inclinations you're like oh my
God we've invented creative machines for
the first time in human history this is
amazing uh uh you know bullshitters well
but but also in the good sense
of that word there's there's there are
Shades of Gray though it's interesting
so we had this conversation where you
know we're looking at my firm at Ai and
lots of domains and one of them is the
legal domain so we had this this
conversation with this big Law Firm
about how they're thinking about using
this stuff and we we went in with the
assumption that an llm that was going to
be used in the legal industry would have
to be 100 truthful right verified you
know there's this case where this lawyer
apparently submitted a GPT uh generated
brief and it had like fake you know
legal case citations in it and the judge
is gonna he's gonna get his law license
stripped or something right so so like
we we just assumed it's like obviously
they're going to want the super literal
like you know one that never makes
anything up not the creative one but
actually they said with what the law
firm basically said is yeah that's true
at like the level of individual briefs
but they said when you're actually
trying to figure out like legal
arguments right like you you actually
you you actually want to be creative
right you don't again there's creativity
and then there's like making stuff up
like what's the line you actually want
it you want to explore a different
hypotheses right you want to do kind of
the legal version of like improv or
something like that where you want to
float different theories of the case and
different possible Arguments for the
judge and different possible Arguments
for the jury by the way different routes
through the you know sort of history of
all the of all the case laws so they
said actually for a lot of what we want
to use it for we actually want it in
creative mode and then basically we just
assume that we're going to have to
cross-check all of the um you know all
the specific citations and so I think I
think there's could be more Shades of
Gray in here than people think
um and then I just add to that you know
another one of these trillion dollar
kind of questions is ultimately you know
sort of the verification thing and so um
you know is will will will llms be
evolved from here to be able to do their
own fascial verification
um will you have sort of add-on
functionality like like well from alpha
right where um you know in other plugins
where where that's the way you do the
verification you know another by the way
another idea is you might have a
community of LMS on any you know so for
example you might have the creative LM
and then you might have the literal llm
fact check it right and so there's a
variety of different technical
approaches that are being applied to
solve the hallucination problem um you
know some people like yeah lacun argue
that this is inherently an unsolvable
problem but most of the people working
in the space I think think that there's
a number of practical ways to kind of
kind of Corral this in a little bit